bonjour gerra vespière merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france on vient
de voir donc de nouvelles scènes de
violence ces dernières heures au proche
orient
jusqu'où est ce que ça peut aller et
bien bonjour d'abord écouter et je pense
que les choses devraient heureusement se
calmer parce que l'état israélien ne
peut pas faire face à des difficultés
extérieures et intérieures en même temps
aussi nombreuses dans le cadre d'un
nouveau gouvernement qui n'a que six
semaines d'existence et une seule voix
de majorité
donc il faut effectivement que ces deux
causes de mouvement et d'incidents
meurtriers en cisjordanie à savoir des
contrôles situe sécuritaire et puis
d'autre part des manifestations contre
les colonies et bien que ces deux causes
puisse avoir un effet de calme parce que
autrement la situation devrait pouvoir
être difficile
justement elle pourrait être difficile
jusqu'à quel niveau est ce qu'il ya un
risque de revenir à la situation du
printemps dernier durant lesquelles
durant lequel plusieurs affrontements
avaient opposé israéliens et
palestiniens avant que ça déjà
ressources ou virant confirmée entre
israël et le hamas avec 260 mans à la
clé on le rappelle d'écouter le problème
enfin en tout cas d espèce et le système
mis en place par par israël à savoir la
présence militaire l'espace son pad
des policiers sont pas des gendarmes ce
sont des forces militaires qui sont
présentes a premièrement donc quelles
que soient les causes des événements
comme je disais soit manifestation à soi
contrôle sécuritaire à c'est l'armée qui
intervient et l'armée donc est doté de
moyens les taux n'ont pas de lancement
de bâle ii défensive mais de balle
offensive était donc là il y a un
deuxième volet qui posait problème
donc premier la présence de l'armée
deuxième l'équipement blindés et la
coalition actuelle sans du gouvernement
israël
qui comprend notamment des partis arabes
est ce que ça peut être un moyen
d'apaiser le conflit israélo palestinien
il faut le souhaiter je crois que
effectivement il y a après 16 ans de
netanyahou ce donc maintenant une
volonté de recentrage de la population
qui a voté en faveur de gouvernement ce
qui élargit finalement pas ce qu'il y à
un émiettement à politique en israël et
donc pour constituer un gouvernement
majoritaire
il faut regrouper des forces et niété
dont pour la première fois un parti
arabe
donc là le dialogue a lieu à l'intérieur
d'israël à l'alte rigueur de la
politique israélienne entre donc par lui
même religieux juifs et puis minorité
arabe
et puis tout favorable à la fin des
colonies israéliennes qui se trouvent en
cisjordanie territoire palestinien
occupé reconnu illégales au regard du
droit international est ce que c'est
l'une des solutions pour essayer de
marquer la fin de ce conflit est et
comment peut et va agir cette fameuse
nouvelle coalition gouvernementale qui
m'a donc on le rappelle de l'ultra
droite nationaliste avec le premier
ministre
naftali bennett et puis ce
park arabe donc mais tout est déjà un
des incidents qui viennent qui vient de
se dérouler derrière dernier ces
derniers jours il est par des
manifestations autour de la colonie de
hevia tard gates a donc eu la israël a
décidé de retirer les colons nes par les
colons ont laissé les mobil homes
mais la population donc israélienne est
partie des colons israéliens sont partis
donc il ya quand même un dosage
politique un arbitrage politique à la
présence contenant les dans les colonies
ou en tout cas dans l'extension de
nouvelles colonies
il s'en est donc vraiment un souci de
contrôler et de ne pas aggraver la
situation
dernière question quid de la communauté
internationale est bien le malt et
internationale donc effectivement est en
difficulté elle a toujours condamné
l'occupation dans les territoires donc
en cisjordanie récemment il ya eu des
décisions d'une entreprise même pour ne
plus commercialiser des produits
fabriqués à partir donc de ce territoire
au nom des colonies israéliennes
donc voilà il ya des décisions qui sont
défavorables il sarel des amis de la
présence dans l'est dans les territoires
mais c'est quand même
l'état hébreu qui a le dernier mot et
donc la main sur ces décisions haute
monde politique et stratégie merci
gérard vestiaire je rappelle que vous
êtes fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté